breaking news right now this just
happened apparently on Tucker Carlson
the fake ramaswamy announces 2024
presidential bid just a moment ago Ian
was talking about a potential Underdog I
think that was you right Ian uh I think
Bill brought it up you brought up
someone an underdog or someone coming in
and we said yay or psychic uh and then
literally like as you were saying this
it's like 8 20 so it's about half an
hour ago conservative author and
businessman businessman Vivek ramaswamy
announced Tuesday he is running for
president in the 2024 race I'm assuming
as a republican if he's launching on
Tucker quote we're in the middle of this
national identity crisis Tucker where we
have celebrated our diversity and our
differences for so long
that we forgot all the ways we really
are the same as Americans Bound by a
common set of ideals that set this
nation into motion 250 years ago I'm
proud to say I'm running for you United
States president to revive those ideas
ideals in this country those basic rules
of the road meritocracy the idea you get
ahead in this country not in the color
of your skin but in the content of your
character our diversity is meaningless
if nothing greater binds us together
that's really great um I like the guy
we've had him on the show before but I
gotta be honest
uh DeSantis is as close as you can get
to competition to Donald Trump and even
then it's a long shot I mean we see Paul
as they go back forth but Trump is
consistently the guy and I think the
reason is Trump woke up a lot of Voters
who did not vote before but now are and
they are loyal to Trump you also need
someone with hundreds of millions of
followers to have any chance to come out
of nowhere so you need like a mega
influencer like
the rock or someone like that on that
level I'm not saying that he should
probably yeah exactly you need to be at
the absolute top tier of you know online
personality to to come out anyone want
to be president well that's what I keep
thinking not everyone wants to be
president but some people want to launch
a presidential campaign get the exposure
and then produce another book or get a
you know show on a fox or whatever I
want to be like we are diverting funds
to East Palestine we're going to use
some experimental technology and see if
we can pull this chemicals out of the
river with magnets we're doing it and
we're sending 600 million dollars into
this thank you for your taxes and that I
want to be able to do that and I think
the president can do that kind of thing
I don't want I don't want to get killed
off all the other stuff that the
president has to deal with too no I want
to play Divinity too but I feel like I
have to to get it done yo uh so as
everybody knows I'm watching uh
Yellowstone I'm on season five now and
it's really great when uh the main
character is now the Governor John
Dutton or you know and then it's like
you have a meet with this group and he's
like why and they're like your advisor's
plan is like firewood no one told me
that and he's like walks in the room
you're all fired get out and basically
they're telling him like here's your new
policy initiative and he's like no it
isn't I never agreed to that that's how
it is the president you're going to walk
in and they're going to be like here's
your plan for schools you got it the CIA
is going to walk and say Here's the war
action you're taking in Afghanistan
You're Gonna Go sure Donald Trump was
probably the first guy in a long time
ago excuse me no not my plan you're
fired and they got mad because like if
you don't repurpose the world because
I'd be like okay Lockheed we're going to
repurpose the weapons let's blow some
chemicals up on Mars and heat up the
atmosphere but they might be like well
if we do that then the Chinese are going
to take Taiwan the Russians are going to
take Crimea if we if we nuke Mars if we
if we redivert the military-industrial
complex into something less violent and
start using its thermonuclear
capabilities to heat up the atmosphere
on Mars for instance as opposed to
killing people on Earth and laying
Rubble to cities that's at least a use
of the materials so that they can keep
making money but the argument might be
like well then Russia is going to take
Crimea and then Poland's next like you
need to defend against psychosis maybe
and then it's like at that point maybe I
do maybe maybe the military industrial
complex is legit who do you guys think
Trump picks as VP John Dutton
I'm just kidding you're in the real
world who do you think I mean Kevin
Costner would not be a bad pick yeah but
he's amazing no the thing is yeah I
think I think that John Dutton uh when
he accepts that he's going to be
Governor like I am the wall that
progress smashes against speech is all
right it's one of the best speeches I've
ever heard in TV that doesn't mean
anything I watch a lot of TV but uh why
are people saying that show is woke I
don't get it I don't I think it's that
one character but you know whatever the
activist lady yeah the the
daughter-in-law but because they make
him a villain subtly John yeah I think I
have never I've always rooted for that
in family when I watch this yeah but
maybe that's because he's a hero and
villain simultaneously I mean that's
like the suburbation that's what's
interesting about his character like the
things that he is villainized for
wanting you actually also sympathize
with like he wants to protect his
family's Legacy I'm not totally kidding
when I say John Dutton would be a good
VP pick like someone who is dedicated to
ideals that Americans feel like have
been lost right someone who can openly
say that like I put my family first I
put my Community First that would really
be powerful I think one of the downsides
of trump is that he is a celebrity he is
extremely wealthy I mean Pence there's
no way he comes back with pets right and
the other thing is that Pence hit the
Christian conservative Midwest you know
triangulate that they wanted but he
wasn't enough of a personality to
balance Trump and I think that is why
they picked him on the other hand
Americans want to know that there are
other people like Trump so this has got
to be DeSantis you think so if Trump if
the ticket was trying
I would imagine you know let's let's uh
let's do this you ready guys
if it's Trump DeSantis on the ticket
we're talking 49 State Landslide here
okay now in all seriousness you go ahead
and clip that Media Matters or whoever
else I think that uh you'll see a decent
Point swing you might see like a you
know like like a 51 or some not it's not
going to be 49 49 49.5 49.8 or whatever
you might actually get 52 percent Trump
and DeSantis I think
DeSantis gets you a lot of the more
moderate people who are like well he's
going to keep Trump in line a little bit
give him good advice and he's going to
uh he's gonna advise on policy better
plus being president of the Senate will
be really really great Donald Trump is
the is the Arrogant guy who's gonna go
and clean house I think that works if
they team up
that's a that that is beyond a winning
ticket because democracy was struggling
Tulsi with Trump no no no no no no I
mean I like Tulsi but I I I I think she
would be a Cabinet member
we got we got a year or so but you come
to me and you say Donald Trump is
running with the Santas as a VP
Tulsi gabbard is campaigning for them
planning to be a national security
advisor and I'm just like
for that Administration you know what I
mean it's not perfect but I talked about
this with uh I think that this sorry
this just shows how
um used we are to having bad leaders
the fact that but I hear what you're
saying like Tulsi is so bad I don't see
Tulsi as presidential because even when
you look at her campaign in in 2019 2020
it was very very much just about the war
machine
and I can respect your position on that
like I I I I think she's she's great
she's come around a lot of issues too
she was pro-gun control now she's eased
up on it but I see her primarily being a
a the inversion of John Bolton somebody
you bring us a national security advisor
who is going to help work towards these
peace deals in positive ways I see Ron
DeSantis as the CEO a guy who knows how
to make these things happen he's he's
he's straight to the point he's in touch
Donald Trump is the he's literally even
right now the CEO he's the crazy guy
with the vision that says this is what
the people want this is what we got to
do he likes to sit around watching Fox
News he's not going to be the guy to go
out and lift the heavy rocks and get the
job done that's going to be a DeSantis
and then with the Tulsi Garrett on
National Security oh man I mean that
would just be a plus plus I would I
think they would what about Tucker
yeah I don't know no he's not he's not a
policy guy Tucker is a uh he's a Bard
right and he's he's you know he speaks
people listen he shares ideas people
listen but he's not
the commander-in-chief he's the lookout
you know what I mean
I think there'll be a push for uh
Christie gnome because she's young
conservative female she's from uh South
Dakota I don't I think you're right
DeSantis is the strongest choice but if
we're just saying who else might come up
uh and again she's someone who could
have a nice political future she's very
loyal to Trump but I think DeSantis
it adds to the legacy of like the mega
move and I think that's what's hard
people don't know people who are really
behind Trump 100 feel strongly about the
call to Maga America First don't know
who takes up the crown after Trump's
runs out of chances to be in office
right like if he's reelected that's his
last term he can't go again and so
naming DeSantis as your VP or again
someone young someone who seems like
they can carry forth this movement that
is a vote for the future for the people
who believe in this movement because
they saw what happens if there isn't
someone to take Donald Trump's place
it's also interesting like are you
remember the unity project yeah
and then went after him yeah they got
censored but it's also just sad how such
a well-intentioned project just like
doesn't gain steam you know it's like
when because unless you ride the divide
and just take advantage of the hyper
politicization on each side like for
some reason just being balanced is not
interesting to people
it's sad I think it's like we're in the
sports team mentality though you have to
vote you have to get really excited
about your candidate and they have to
have a brand they have to feel like
you're you're really buying into
something and when you're neutral when
you want to hear both sides of the
argument when you want to just advise
people to come together it doesn't feel
competitive and although we need it and
although it's important it doesn't win
votes the same way
unfortunately you think it's just
because well I think it's because the
media wants division divisiveness to
sell clicks and to generate the War uh
fervor whether it's the person that you
hate or the person that's doing their
bidding they want one of those guys in
the spotlight yeah I was looking at a
bunch of YouTube
content and stuff and uh
man it is it is demoralizing quite a bit
I I see so much content on Twitter and
on YouTube and on Facebook that is
beyond clickbait hyperbole right I know
like you know the the title of this
video right now is like Russia ends last
nuclear treaty Trump warns of world
warns of World War III those are literal
things that happened it you know I
didn't I didn't put the headline world
war three is now Putin threatens nukes
the treaty is over I said Russia ends
last nuclear treaty he did Trump warns
of World War III he did granted I want
it to be like enticing I want to grab
your attention but man I got Scruples
and I'm looking at a lot of people and
they'll get more views by saying
something more like World War Three just
started Vladimir Putin threatens to Nuke
after dissolving treaty Donald Trump is
terrified or something like really just
driving it and that's not even the most
extreme like the example I see often is
like some dude will you know trip and
fall and then the video will be titled
dude gets into horrific accident
grotesque injuries morbid and then you
click it and it's a guy like rubbing his
shin because he bumped into to a curb or
something it's like the stuff that gets
attention
what everyone's striving for is the most
extreme headline and so one of the
problems we have right now with news in
order to attract attention you have to
one-up yourself every single time thus
the narrative emerging on Twitter is
increasingly getting unhinged and we're
addicted we need more we need more to
trigger that dopamine thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time